first or somebody dealing with
immigrants and refugees child sexual
abuse jails the prison system older
people it was trauma across the spectrum
and it was really amazing to have these
conversations with people but I was
struck with the fact that a lot of the
work that I've done for 25 years has
been the people who are like shrapnel
you know which we said about crossing
the boulevard it was the people that
were flung here the people that got out
the people who didn't get killed right
we're seeing it now right with Syrian so
many Syrians fleeing that it's like
there needs to be this unbelievable
cleanup crew all the time for the
atrocities that happen on so many levels
so that was a really interesting
conference for me TP @ & at the how many
of you are going to the oral history
conference in Tampa great well at that
conference of doing the whole illness
show as part of the keynote on Saturday
night and I'll tell you something I was
surprised that they want to do with and
I say that because of just like the
field of oral history and I'm playing
with things in so many experimental ways
but the technology allows me now to have
the dialogue with people on stage who
aren't here now you know tour
you know the kids because you heard
there don't whiskers so we have some
time for some questions and I just
wanted to make sure that we left some
time for that I'll also let me know that
I have books and CDs and stuff here for
sale if anybody wants them there's like
19 cuts of multiple sounds and stories
on the crescent boulevard CA and the
books are here too does anyone have any
questions besides that maybe you want a
napkin it's hot in here am I the only
one without you yeah I one drink thank
you very much I was wondering um so much
you work is lived in books but it does
come from interviews yes so how do you
what here in those interviews so they in
an archive somewhere engaged did you
hear his question what do we do with the
raw interviews the eight hours right
that are still sitting there right now
honestly we're trying to raise money if
anybody knows any funders that we could
go to we have this huge archive of all
of the interviews not just the
interviews from crossing the boulevard
but a gigantic archive of photographs
hundreds and hundreds of photographs and
some of them are just you know like of
Manhattan from you know the Williamsburg
Bridge because you know i was driving
warrant around dropping them off at some
dangerous corner going back and picking
him up so he can get these shots but we
have time to photograph the Queen
library
the one on merrick boulevard the main
library they have an incredible archive
if any of you are ever doing any
research it's amazing and the archivist
there is amazing I went there to do
another project they wanted but we need
to organize it and I really just want to
raise money to hire somebody to help
organize it because it's so many
photographs somebody's going to have to
catalog yet somebody's going to have to
organize all those and and they want it
so we know we have a home for it the
exhibit eventually is going to be part
of the permanent collection at the
Queens museum of art but they are
construction is so slow that they don't
have you know they've been like got a
city grant to that live long enough
forget it mommy that their constructions
going so slow I'm hoping within two
years so yeah it's going to be somewhere
and if you want to get on our mailing
list just go to irse to work for those
duties that have to leave so yeah there
is an archived endless amounts of tape
but you know I want to ask a question
who really listens to art who goes into
archive scholars right it's people at
universities because a lot of my work is
about not keeping the interviews in a
tight vault but how am I going to get
these stories out publicly in an art
form that I think people can engage with
so that's what I've been doing you know
for most of my life but I do see the
value of the archive yeah and it's all
digital so
yeah I'm just curious about how your
subject certain areas yep experience you
were boards and crafting Andrey crafting
right so uh different ways the other
night three people came from crossing
the boulevard to the performance that
there were a couple of people there was
quite interesting mostly people are kind
of proud really proud to be part of this
because it was to chuck a exquisite art
project so everybody was really proud to
have a book bhavik always says it's his
book not that there's 78 other people in
it and it's interesting for me that
people take ownership of it that way we
made a mistake in here even though we
gave a Ramona Paula from the Philippines
the spreads and hadn't read it there was
still a mistake in Tagalog in there
devastated so ninotchka the woman who's
a mistake is in will it like called me
but she had a sense of humor about it
seriously what 30 different languages
the possibility for error was high it
was proof read many many times so for
the most part people were really happy
too and proud to be part of that the I
think I told you like the dialogues I
had with some of the older Jews where it
got tricky it's like I don't want to
talk to if you do this and so we
negotiated that which also meant that I
could never do the character anywhere in
a school
sitting on stage for five minutes that
was only funny I won't just never do
that the character so that became a real
a real relationship and the woman from
Mississippi was completely she was in
the rehearsal process when we did it at
La MaMa she was worried about things
that I never would have thought she was
worried about a story that she told me
that I thought was really important
where she said at one point she's being
followed by the local sheriff and her
life was just really turned upside down
she had to leave town eventually but she
said y'all see this ness mirrors out
there on the I'm attorney hanging the
way they are didn't look nice reflecting
the light looks like a nice mobile you
know why I put it there that's to
reflect their hate back at them and I
think it's working too when I did that
story in a rehearsal just like oh you
got to cut that out and I said why I
think it's so interesting that you would
create something that you felt like was
a barrier and she said people will think
I'm crazy they'll think I'm a witch I
think um and so we convinced her to let
us do it a couple of nights and see how
the audience responded so people often
will say things to me that I don't
expect junior and I mean like that's not
that's not the story I thought she would
have had a hard time when I thought she
was going to have a hard time he
revealing that she became bulimic in the
process of being a civil rights person
and being on The Oprah Winfrey Show and
she got really large and then she
thought what people will only pay
to me it fun thin and I thought well
she'll never go for that and then she
thought no you have to tell that story
you know those kinds of things have been
complicated and then one person who
originally thought that the whole
project was about her also and I think
because the English was such a big
problem she wouldn't we showed her the
book she actually like started sobbing
because she was just one story in it so
then we ended up talking to her family
and we'll have an exhibit that was
really painful for me because I wanted
her to appreciate that her story was
with all these other people and touring
in the mean now that you're asking the
kids have all the kids that I was
representing have all been part of the
dialogue as I was developing you'll miss
because I felt like that was really
important what's going to happen with
the show and toure who I sampled there
was a period of time I mean such a good
question what you're asking that he
so a workshop version of the show where
I had an actor on stage kind of doing
some things and he hated and he hated it
because it was always getting
misdirected and he felt like it was
caricature earlish of him and so I said
well should we try just recording
recreating our argument and see what
happens and so he decided to do that in
the studio let's recreate it because now
you can do it with bluetooth and that
was really interesting and I remember
saying to him recently oh you hated the
way the black male characters were
raishin including Dale I say from
StoryCorps have you listened to some of
those pieces or his early stuff so a lot
of people have really been influenced by
that has anyone here seen the slave
narratives or Unchained memories that
was on HBO that Oprah Winfrey did but
the slave narratives are at the
Smithsonian have you seen them and I
have the cds and they're really
interesting to listen to because they
are written out in the vernacular of
what how people spoke so if somebody was
saying I was oh that's how it was
written but that's how it sounds and
that the people that did that there's
some complicated things with the slave
narratives because who's taking the oral
history who's listening is it a person
who was not personally connected to
anybody who was a former slave it was
the 1930s there was four over there was
audio what a great amazing gift that
people were able to listen to those
voices before those people died most of
the people were in their 90's or
hundreds and so you know what a great
moment to be able to record people and
get the stories if somebody was going to
not believe oh my god really your master
you know put your hand under
rocking chair and rocked the chair over
your hand really know that didn't happen
so depending on who was listening to the
story there was a lot of a lot written
about that project about who was
believed right or how much you're going
to tell somebody if you feel like you're
listen to if I'm telling you a story and
I feel like you just don't believe what
I'm saying I'm gonna shut it down and so
that that project was really good for me
to read and also just to see like what
are people telling to who they're always
and that's the thing about oral history
and journalism you know nobody's
completely objective we're all hearing a
story as it hits us in our experience of
what we've seen or what we've lived and
so some stories stay with you in a
different way so I'll very sturdy I'm
going to do a character that was based
on oral histories of Holocaust survivors
which was one of the first projects I
did based on people's stories isn't that
better sort of although we have the
wrong picture oh whatever um well that's
interesting so God you know when I was
22 I got very interested in listening to
older people and that means people that
were in their 80s and 90s and I didn't
have living grandparents and so perhaps
that was some of it because I think
people do projects that are also somehow
soulfully driven there's something in
your psyche in your soul as an artist
that you want to do you know it's not
arbitrary is anyone familiar with may
sarton ones writing she's a poet I went
and interviewed her who she's a tough
cookie um and she was probably in her
late 70s when I interviewed her and it
was the time of like political
correctness in the universities and she
had said to me you know she was very
very very controlling of her time she
looked at me and she said what the hell
are you going to be able to do you know
you're so young why are you interested
in journal of a solitude and so I
started talking to her about having
grown up where my dad died and my
grandmother died and all these things
happened and I felt like an adult when I
was 12 so she kind of talked to me after
that and she was also very um at the
time she was getting some letters from
some lesbians in the she was a lesbian
by the way she was and she was fairly
out about it
places and she thought that it really
hurt her she was friends with Eva legaly
and this is like you know may sarton
would have been wet like 110 by now
maybe or something and she told me that
she had gotten some letters from some
college students telling her like how
she had to identify herself and it was
really interesting to me because she got
very angry about it but she had a sense
of humor she said well what are they
doing telling me how I should be a
lesbian I'm 78 years old ID I've been a
lesbian all my life and it was this kind
of identity politics that was I think
there's a brazenness too sometimes when
you're young right like this is this is
the way we're going to frame identity
politics and so I told her I wasn't
going to do that I just wanted to know
the heart of her story but you know
having an experience like that when
you're 21 22 where somebody's like
throwing everything in your face
immediately and not hiding was really
instrumental for me and then I started
performing in a company and I started
doing some solo shows and I just got
interested in creating characters and
this character popped out of me that was
an older Jewish lady and also some other
characters as well but this one
character got really interesting and I
talked to somebody from the National
Endowment for the Humanities and a
scholar that was
in Connecticut at the time is anybody
from new haven or familiar with New
Haven there was a woman that was just
starting to do Holocaust interviews at
Yale in the 80s and this was before
Spielberg and I'd say that because in
the culture that we're in we've seen
movies right the Holocaust is like a
movie you know it's it's been
commercialized it's already in the
dialogue of what I remember telling
people you know there wasn't any mention
of the Holocaust on American television
until nineteen seventy eight as like a
real thing not you know in some sitcom
or something that and people don't
really 1978 so it kind of makes sense
right that in the 80s a lot of the older
people that we approach to interview
were what why do you want to interview
me or their children who were now in
their 60s and were why do you want to
interview my mother what are you what
are you digging around in and this idea
that we really wanted to capture the
stories before they died and I also
interviewed a lot of older European Jews
I made a joke in the introduction to
crossing the boulevard and it's not just
a joke it's real that when I grew up in
New Haven most of my friends were Jewish
Italian Porto Rican and african-american
New Haven was um about I think well the
schools were like eighty five percent
black when I went to school so there
were very few white people there was
white flight if people could leave they
left a lot of black middle class people
sent their children to private schools
because the schools were so nutty and is
anyone familiar with New Haven
at all like it's a very funny little
town it's not easy to pack it's
Connecticut but when I grew up it was
very rough like there was a kid with a
switchblade at my high school you know
which switchblade I had held to my
throat was the first time I saw switch
boy was 115 but in the introduction to
cresting the boulevard I said that when
I was a kid most of the older people i
knew the grandparents they were from
somewhere else so i thought that the
aging process was developing wrinkles a
stoop and a foreign accent because
everybody's grandparents had hudson and
i thought i was gonna grow up a foreign
accent that's cool and it was just a
child like view of what the aging
process was but of course then I
realized now there were particular
people people work from somewhere else
so I started this project and it was a
very long project it was three years and
somebody in the class here at Columbia
asked me earlier about partnerships that
was also a partnership with a housing
center of senior housing center with um
senior centers in New Haven and the
older people in New Haven represented
the demographic of who was in New Haven
so it was older European Jews Italians
and black Americans from the south and
it migrated up that older group of
people right so I ended up doing this
character and I'm going to perform a
little bit of her and maybe with some of
the story the kind of story that would
have come from someone it was an amalgam
I guess in the way that Eve Ensler said
that she interviewed whatever 100
50 people and sometimes made composites
and then I'll tell you a story about
what one of the women from Stanford
Connecticut who I interviewed who had
survived a camp and then became on the
board of Amnesty International what she
had said to me after our interview and
she almost retracted her interview so
I'm telling you that because this is an
audience that's of this work and so I
think you might find some of this stuff
of the nuance of how to get it like
settled in your own body and what's your
relationship to people interesting as
opposed to just the Performing all right
they done mean it I'm gonna tell you a
little story yeah look at you you'll
know me yeah look apparel laughing like
that that's good for you you jiggle up
and down like that you're going to be
very healthy I read something about it
in the book you laugh a lot you jiggle
up and down releases an enzyme and your
body helps to fight viruses yeah you
can't see me you have a gold you feel
bad enough all right well I was gonna
tell you one little story yeah they
asked me Buddha my grandson event a
college very good that event to graduate
school valina
then he tells me is going to graduate
school again I tell them how many
degrees do you need to have you never
gonna get out of school he's gonna now
he's gonna get a PhD is gonna do this
she's going to do that but he's taking a
graduate class alright and he tells me
he has to do some homework I'll write a
paper assignment I call it home what
does he want to do he wants to video
tape me talking to him about things a
hell in my apartment alright so I'm his
homework I'm going through everything he
sees the pictures on my dresser who's
this watch this you know I never knew
about this so he's looking at the
photograph of mine cousin mark he never
met she was a lot older than I am and
you know that's very old gear but she's
not here anymore so he wants to know the
story Malcolm she was a survivor she
didn't live in again and survived again
she survived in hiding I don't know if
you know the difference but there's a
difference but Mulcair because she went
from one country to another she spoke by
different language
she didn't know this was just gonna help
her survive when she was I think but
when she came to New York they want why
because the welfare that's bringing in
the new refugees they need somebody who
can speak a lot of languages because the
new people coming from the displaced
poisons can wherever they are they don't
know what language they're speaking my
be Russian maybe polish maybe Ukrainian
maybe Roshan I said the ocean or at the
end up wanting yes I'm getting a little
lost that's all I guess what happens in
old age so she speaks languages when she
was all there in her old age I tell my
grandson baby she was telling me Sophie
they're gonna find out they're gonna
find out won't mind they're gonna find
out this is what she was repeating I
didn't know maybe she was Xena what was
she saying they're gonna find out I used
to take care of in their own age so one
day I say mark of what
is it voiceover it your all came here
and this is the story that she told me I
told it to my grandson and he put it on
the camera
marker she had a clean
read in the welfare department the lady
had survived Auschwitz she came and
malkovich ibas supposed to do not that
different than today with a refugee you
find an apartment some place for them to
be for three months and you try and find
something that they can do but first you
find them a place to live so she finds
the lady a place to live in New York
City alright this is a 1950s and the
next day the baby comes back DaMarcus
office she says I cannot live in that
apartment I don't know what language she
was speaking I don't remember but she
was hysterical I cannot leave him and
believing I did not live in the building
Marcus it talked to me she brought the
rain she closed the door and the woman
told her she cannot live in that
building because in that building there
is an incinerator for the garbage how
can do the lady wasn't crazy she had
survived Auschwitz she doesn't want to
live in that building should go crazy so
she switched the papers and she gave her
a different apartment she wasn't
supposed to do that she lied to her
supervisor she didn't tell she switched
apartments she made a special
accommodation for the lady this is what
she was worried about her whole life
they were gonna find out she fits the
madness I tell him I
you got this to worry the welfare
department they can find something from
last week they're not gonna give me a
little bit that came apart in front of
you so all right that's what happens in
old age you get to be like an onion you
pay the vendor skinnier than you cry I
don't know I'll tell you I told you the
story do you think I did the right thing
by telling my grandson he's gonna show
to his college are they gonna understand
I don't know you'll know my friends we
took long enough we'll find out we're
related yeah they'll be tired you come
visit me another day next time I'll tell
you a different study yeah sure
that character was a story that lasted
for 45 minutes she had stuff in her bag
she took things out of her bag explained
to the audience who was who and you know
I remember thinking at the time about
for any of us that right about war
stories there's much more consciousness
right now in 2015 then there was even 15
years ago about what is called sdsd or
you could call living with memories of
harbor right with the whole idea of
living in a building with an incinerator
did anybody live in New York long enough
to live in buildings when they had
incinerators for the garbage I remember
that as a little kid visiting my
mother's relatives that I was so like oh
my god they have like you put the
garbage down and in the building um so I
was thinking about those kinds of
stories and how they live with people
and we don't know what somebody's living
with right we don't know what the person
is living with who's you know working
behind the counter you know serving
people coffee so that was kind of an
interesting lighthouse that's just a one
little story within a larger range of
stories but the character was always
going through a range of humor and pain
really really serious stories and and
funny stories and now I'll tell you the
story that the woman
to me about so she was 90 years old I
had interviewed about probably 65 people
somewhere Holocaust survivor son warrant
and she called me and she said she
suddenly got really nervous about what I
was going to do with the stories and she
said I don't want you to use any of my
story if it's just going to be funny
because you know there's a lot of stuff
on mainstream television where people
kind of write that character could be
like a humorous character and I promised
her that I wouldn't and there have been
times while I was performing in theaters
where some commercial more commercial
minded person had come up to meet
several this happened over the years
several times oh we can take just that
one little element of that character and
use it for a commercial or use it for oh
we love that character and I would never
do it because it would be a total
betrayal of my soul but also of that
including that that I made with her
about how is the story going to get used
the other thing that struck me and I
don't know if this is just amount of
time you spend with people but because i
grew up in new haven there were some
people who knew my father even though he
had died
when I was a kid so the mind if we
talked long enough we'll find out
whether lated it came from a woman who I
actually knew her granddaughter's but I
didn't realize it till the third time I
had interviewed her and I saw a picture
and she said oh who are you and so it
was interesting to me and then I asked
her oh I said that line is really
interesting i think i'd like to use it
in a different way so that character
became like a lighthouse even though
people don't use lighthouses this way
anymore it's all satellites but the way
a lighthouse shows you where to go you
know there's some deep waters here and
where am I going to go so that character
kind of became a lighthouse in terms of
the ethics what I was going to do how I
was going to perform and that balance I
did a show in Stanford Connecticut for
only Holocaust survivors which would be
impossible now because most people are
gone but it was like one of the best and
I don't be best like theatrically but it
was one of the best experiences of my
life theatrically as well because there
was a safety and understanding that
we're going to go back and forth between
a horrible story and some humor because
the humor allows us to live and that
taught me something also there's a limit
to how much you can with distance you
can't have humor oh no it's very hard of
humor right when you're in the middle of
the horror so that led me to working on
a project believe it or not and
Mississippi in the 90s I went down to do
some work and i met this woman who was
talking about something that had
happened there where she had blown the
whistle on the Pops with shoes white
blonde blue haired blue eyed freckles
with three black officers and
and went down with a another reporter
and we did a documentary where we did
both things it was a theater piece and
it was a radio documentary so we use the
theater piece intercut with some of the
real people and if we could play that
news on that it be found put up my with
a yellow thing and then I'll tell you a
little bit about the real woman too but
we'll play just a little bit of it
because when you're doing a project then
for another entity right now this is not
just for the theater it's also going to
be for NPR and so it's going to be
couched in their framework doesn't it
soon appear to to somebody to chair I'm
burning the group can you get seven
children we were aware early on that the
South was different from other places
and whether we spelled it or sit em I SS
I SS IP piatti we believed Mississippi
to be yet another place apart when I was
a child I heard stories Mississippi was
where it was commonplace for black
people to come up missing we surmised
mississippi had its own laws and the
walls not on our side but no matter
whether it was carolina alibi
or Mississippi the South was our home
the memories of those bitter times are
mixed with an appreciation for the
beauty of the South the greedy kudzu
vines the ancient Spanish oak trees and
the sound evening freight trains on
horizons today we'll go to Harrison
County Mississippi and we'll go back in
time to the fall 1989 today's program is
a doctor's loan the story of four deputy
sheriff's who brought charges of abuse
in a juvenile detention center our
producers are Laura Sydell and Gina's
slow sometimes one of it can change the
source of a life that's what interested
or historian and actress to the throne
and she met Andrea gifts while
performing in Mississippi she was
sobbing and begging for help she said
she was being violent and was getting
death threats and phoned I didn't think
anyone could make up so many details
then she told me the entire story my
head was spinning I never feared was
real but I wasn't sure what to do I was
very naive and I believe that if I did
what was right that other people would
follow soon join in helping that it
would all like being like this wonderful
Cinderella fairy tale where you know the
liquid stepmother gets you in trouble
one we all go on to live princess lies
it's just didn't happen the way
in 1989 Andrea get stupid job as a
deputy sheriff in the juvenile detention
center in Harrison County four hours
into her first ship Gibbs claims she
witnessed officers being an inmate and
the band's continued for the next eight
months exactly what gifts saw is still
disputed by many in the county
fascinated with his tail Sloane created
a play based on gives pilgrimage in and
out of law enforcement change of your
gifts as well as other key players
involved in the story a dozen supporters
are plotted before deputies that are
finally speaking out today and we have
gives Tony Lewis Willie Williams and
voice Grayson said they were threatened
with their jobs and their lives if they
didn't help cover up alleged beatings
and abuse at the Heritage my name is
Louise Taylor ever could like son Harry
in Biloxi Mississippi and I covered the
jail beings saga when it occurred in
1989 1990 we have a photograph on the
front page and they were all in uniform
there are four deputies sitting at a
table in a law office I always had the
impression from the Sheriff's Department
and I don't know but that's what really
got there good was the fact that those
deputies were wearing in uniform it
wasn't the same effect if you had
broader deputy sheriffs sitting up there
roaring bell caps and t-shirts and it
was that day the day that's better man
they were fired for violating the chain
of command
okay myself in lies in you and I
realized that because i resided and
didn't say anything that I Haswell been
done hogging all the kids just as soon
as they were and I became a law
enforcement officer because I wanted to
use those skills to better my community
and I felt that the only way I could do
that was to expose in illegal activities
and the horses were going on in jails
i'm jose i'm returning to their get more
supplies they had their own agenda that
they had problems with the department
they were going to be fired like it from
this condom and what you got to do you
got to go be hand the actual that time
they testified and look at the
circumstances leading up to my name is
Judith Sloan I portray a character based
on Andrew Gibbs part of what intrigued
me about andrea was her motivation to
become a law enforcement officer and I
knew the play needed to address that
motivation i began to reconstruct her
memories well away from home when I was
13 years old and I locked up 15 does it
say so I was just incorrigible when I
finally got myself together three years
later i come back to living mom yeah I
know she's using myself but the three
years of living on the street all summer
on the world high school I'll play so
mom would get hurt jakey doing I thought
love him she did so God then she started
to come go to Mississippi Gulf Coast
Community College and I thought well
hell if she could do that so good night
when both design major in criminal
justice loves it was because we print a
word
my god was working in stitches there is
I knew that felt to be inside looking
out I do that felt like a door slams
shut at night and I really felt like I
can relate to the kids my name is
Kenneth Cole if I called him can see I'm
really knee up approximately 12 years
starting sometime the first day she came
home with very uniform it was tables
excited and the first couple of days you
know it was tough being around her
because you know if he would let this
air about her she was walking on clouds
she cute she was low low you know didn't
she started going through the different
training classes and especially with the
baton class I became her practice dummy
at home and she got quite well at it you
know I was thrown in the floor number of
times i had my badge my gun to your 24
you here to avoid this here is PR 24 now
most y'all know that says that not stick
bill club or veteran but the bishops are
and what you want a criminal justice
school is PR 24 when i first started
what parents stood for just that done
public relations is a blood relation
layer that is very specific rules on how
you can or cannot use beer 24 you see
there's a nerve I'm sorry way you're
supposed to go like this look let that
take them them well and so I'm just
going to stop it there but you know
certainly give everybody the link so it
goes on and she you learn about her
desire to you know do the right thing
we're so this whole idea
becoming a cop having been a juvenile in
juvenile detention it was interesting to
me when I got her to explain about the
billy club you know because at the time
there were so many stories about police
brutality and what you can do in choke
holds and so then when she showed me
where the nerve was on the side of a leg
of thinking oh I'm going to show the
audience that so that they can see you
know that people learn where it is and
then people can make up their own mind
about whatever they think about that use
so we went back and forth between me
doing the character between the real
people and until the story kind of keeps
unfolding and it kind of gets more and
more dire but there were hearings in
Mississippi in 1994 and they actually
Janet Reno went down they have these
gigantic civil rights hearings about all
these deaths that were happening and in
the Mississippi jails so there was some
good that came out of it but same people
are still running the jails you know I
think there were a couple of reporters
who went down after Katrina and I
remember calling Andy this is like years
later because we saw one of the guys
that had been in the Sheriff's
Department that had gotten accused of
brutalizing an inmate and had gotten off
apparently after Katrina there were so
many journalists around the same guy
actually got caught again and ended up
getting going to jail I think she's kind
of wild
so that that show was so intense also
for three years we were going down there
and one of the things that happened is
as we were going through the jails how
many of you have been in lockdown you
know you go inside inside inside and the
doors keep closing you know it's just
like oh my god you know you cannot these
were very uh electronic jail there was a
guy in this jail who was painting in a
studio we're walking through the jail
and I looked at the sheriff and you know
Laura had the microphone on and we were
tag-teaming and I was like keep rolling
you know what the hell is this man hum
he was painting portraits and it turned
out that he was a really good painter
and he was painting portraits of
everybody in the town the mayor the
mayor's wife there are children and she
was an undocumented immigrant who got
picked up in one of the border states
and I found out that the federal
government pays a certain amount of
money to have people in the jail's it's
like you could stay there for a really
long time and I said well surely you're
advocating for him since he's such a
good prisoner right and he said all you
know how things are they move so slowly
it just got weirder and weirder they
would warn more stories like that the
only thing that the civil rights
hearings actually caught the Sheriff's
Department in was misuse of budgetary
funds because they had yes because they
had an order for two thousand frilled
toothpicks and those little hot dogs you
know for because the Sheriff's
Department was using the prisoners at
cocktail parties and using the food the
money for prison food for these cocktail
parties for the elite of the town so
that was the only thing they got caught
on right and so there was just so much
corruption so that story also is the
first time i saw immigrant teenagers
being warehoused i thought whoa they're
just warehoused here happen what's a la
and I didn't know and so I came back I
was working with my friend Camille
matzzie does anybody know her she's
running that international peace and
justice center at communal off school
now and she was working for Human Rights
first so I called her and started
getting all these details that we years
later put in the back of crossing the
boulevard and an immigration timeline of
law and policy because they are not
citizens they could be housed
indefinitely there was indefinite
detention before nine eleven and in 1996
there was a law that went through that
you had to prove credible fear in order
to get asylum here and so there was
actually a Supreme Court ruling in
august of two thousand one that said
that you couldn't keep people
indefinitely in
sale for more than six months but then
911 happened and those laws all got
superseded by the Patriot Act so I had
been steeped in this kind of stuff
before nine eleven and then I started
wondering well what's going on in Queens
so because there were all those stories
in an hour and 15 minute play in a
tattletale this superintendent of the
schools of the alternative schools in
New York asked me if I would come
perform in the jail and when I come
perform in some of the high school and
so it was another path into another
project and that's where this came out
it was a big big crossing the boulevard
project about new immigrants and
refugees who came to queens from all
over the world our criteria was they had
to have live indoor work in Queens they
had to be a character for those of you
that are doing oral history projects now
and you're recording people it does
matter doesn't it how people talk and
what's the emotion coming out of them of
what that's going to be for other people
to care about the story we interviewed
over 150 people and included 79 stories
because everybody did not make it into
this kind of forum where the story would
be a page-turner and i'll just show you
one quick thing that i really appreciate
this woman from Afghanistan she went to
them the reason is cuz she went to
graduate school so she came to the
United States when she was ten years old
with her father after the Soviet Union
in beta
Afghanistan and her father left the
mother there she didn't know the mother
at all because the father got two of the
older daughters and there was a baby
daughter there and then eventually she
brought her mother out of Afghanistan
into queens where they developed a
relationship as mother and daughter as
adults but the mother had lived through
the Taliban lived through I went to
Pakistan and lived in a refugee city for
years and so one of the things that she
came and told me was that she had to
teach her mother how to cross the road
so I say that because it seems like a
monday and think doesn't it you know but
she had to teach her mother this is like
a 13 lane highway here at Queens
Boulevard but one of the things she came
is so here was I think people assume
that of anything from Greek to battalion
to Native American maybe even Hindu but
very few people ever guess that I'm in
Africa so I can sit there like a
chameleon in here when people have to
say I was in an environment where
somebody said we should just go new gift
Gunther they blew up the Twin Towers so
let's get rid of them I spent there
thinking but we didn't do it does 19
hijackers weren't asking at all I
brought like a lot of people in my
generation in Kabul as a secular Muslim
but now after 911 I want to know what
does it say in the Quran about jihad
what does it say about the role of women
what does it say about how to be with
your neighbor I know I'm not going to
find anything that says that you can go
below
my kids are going to be courted Jewish
quarter Christian and half Muslim think
about that when they come home and they
said oh mommy somebody said Islam as a
violent religion I've got to fully be
able to explain Islam to them because I
don't want my children to learn islam
from somebody else so you know she had
this very unusual path she married a man
who was half Jewish and then in the book
she kind of talked about how his father
was afraid that she he said to his son
aren't you afraid she's Muslim you know
she'll kill you in the middle of the
night right the father is saying this
and then the son said to the bother well
you married somebody who was German so
you know when we met you capable you
know she was married to somebody who is
half-jewish but she started her story
kept pouring out and it was one thing
after another and she had many many
ironies like she did all the paperwork
for her aunt to get here from Pakistan
and the day that her aunt with flying
was on 911 and the plane was told to
turn around and go back and if any of
you have done an immigration hearing or
anybody's done a case this is like seven
years of paperwork can she had to start
all over again not to mention that the
aunt was still there by herself so there
were so many stories like this on
resilience and coming back going forward
if there's time during the Q&A I will
play you a little bit boba canto see who
fled on a cargo flight from the former
Democratic from the Democratic with
other
though he was he had to identity papers
and he ended up fleeing and he lost his
wife his daughter and his livelihood and
ended up on a cargo flight in the dark
not knowing where he's going but the
Russian pilot told him that you're going
to JFK and so you know this kind of
thing and then he landed at the what
they're used to be an immigrant I NS
detention center next to JFK and he
spent two years there no access to
outside life i was performing at Bedford
Hills women's prison and I was sharing
this story and some audio and one of the
prisoners said oh I know why it's legal
to keep him in 24 hours with no all of
them you know all the immigrants in
there 24 hours and I said why because
she said because he's not a citizen and
he doesn't have the right to habeas
corpus and so it was interesting to me
that the women in prison knew all of the
legal stuff of why it was okay for the
US government to keep people without
because they had access to an hour of
exercise heated and so at the end he
says this really kind of amazing thing
even though he came out with nothing I'm
going to thank God every day that I did
meet so many friends inside that
nightmare plates from Sri Lanka Pakistan
Santo Domingo from all over the world
I'm going to sing even though I cannot
sing very good because there's no rule
on me that I cannot sing a guard cannot
take you to the clinic like I'm a crazy
person say there's something wrong with
me singing in the dormitory I'm going to
sing on my bed I'm going to sing when
i'm washing I'm going to sing walking on
the street if I meet someone new
this country I'm going to give them the
hospitality that I did not receive
welcoming the people coming I'm going to
correct more than a tenth of my English
that I do have I'm going to get a job in
my field and so it was really amazing
that he said I am going to enjoy the
life now because I have the human right
now I have the right now so that was
kind of the end of his story while he
awaits his engineering certification
certification he works as a receptionist
at a youth hostel welcoming people from
all parts of the globe he was working at
that hostel on Amsterdam Avenue which is
ironic that he did not get a very good
welcome coming in and when when I was
working for lawyers it was a lawyers
Committee for Human Rights this case had
come up and there was a hunger strike
for those of you that have been in New
York for a long time you may remember
reading about this in 1999 there was a
hunger strike at the wackenhut Detention
Center and bhavik was instrumental in
that they almost didn't take his case
because it had gotten botched by his
previous lawyer and his previous lawyer
was just taking money from the brother
in England and not doing anything so we
came up with a lot of stories like that
where you start seeing how vulnerable
people are when you need something I'm
going to switch gears just a little bit
and make sure that I can show you
bunches of different projects so
crossing the boulevard ended up being an
exhibit it ended up being a performance
the book a series of radio
and
boo boo I knew then we discover more
inch of the ground
my headset want you to be a little lamb
we just came to America and and people
it was kind of exciting because in
different galleries especially if it was
in universities it's still touring but
it toward your 10 years because it would
remain in place for six months and so
professors students we just get married
but do their home projects inside
whatever girl taste for bit from student
age of 65 convey their gear front side
I'm ready / he's funny equally and then
so it's important
there's no children double check you
will show them from bullets and beliefs
that misunderstand who they really are
all month and all guns come here though
let's go gunshot come near them I praise
you for what you have done in Jesus name
I pray and I just wanted to do a little
of her because it was one of the things
that I realized when we were in the
Nigerian church she was praying that the
people in her church not get shocked she
was in the Polish church you know we
would sit for hours and people's
churches and mosques and temples that
she was she started talking a lot about
what happened in that neighborhood is
far out the way and we interviewed
several people from her church who
talked a lot about coming here to the
United States from West Africa where
everybody was black and then coming to
New York and having confusion about
black Americans and that disconnect
between black immigrants and black
Americans until they started feeling
like they were black here because what
she said to us is in nigeria there is
Yoruba ego and how
maybe a couple of dozen other tribes and
show at one point she said most of the
congregation don't know where up they
think I'm Europe really I'm from a small
drive in the middle Delta and then she
wears three different kinds of dresses
each week you know one thing I whether
your address next week away the dress of
the ebook next week I was a dress in the
house and she started doing that on
purpose because what she said to us is
look if you go to Nigeria and you are
from Iowa and I'm from New York and
you're from michigan once we get to
Nigeria we're all from the US each said
it's the same thing here we're not
Nigerian we're all these different
tribes but once we get to New York we're
all Nigerian in terms of the way they're
seeing and how the community service we
can turn the light on and let me ask you
I was going to show you one more clip
from a new piece where you'll kind of
see the trajectory and if there's time I
was going to show you a little bit of a
symphony and then take questions do we
have the window our people hot I see a
few people doing this in the back um so
the windows are open that would be great
or maybe I could open this door to we'll
get some more air in here that's okay
err I think what I'll do is stand on the
chair and give me switch to this week
out great so how many guests are here
you're not a Columbia Graduate Student
okay and how many Columbia graduate
students are here so a lot of you are
doing interviews right and you are I
don't know what your projects are like
but one of the things for me as an audio
artist because that's my my real
specialty is working with audio and I
love the sounds of people's voices and
what's the music of the story that their
challenge what are the sounds outside
that are going to be embedded and so I
kept using all that stuff and that led
me to want to use a mix of live audio
how am I going to do these very tight
audio mixes that are like for radio and
do it on stage that's what I was trying
to figure out and it took me about five
years to figure out how to blend all
this stuff about stories in jail
yeah great I know I got it and then the
technology kind of caught up with me
because it's great because I could use I
could use little wireless devices to
trigger things what I didn't have to
have it on my body I could use foot
pedals I have a keyboard I'm also
playing keyboards in this show here's a
story about a girl a boy a child a
grandmother a teacher student now you
own there is a 12 year old 18 year old
16 year old forty-eight-year-old ill I
remember my from Togo Mexican from Sri
Lanka desh mafia the moon Egypt the
story is a story about a girl a boy a
child a grandmother a t-shirt a woman
I'm a man Chou a girl child there's a
nine-year-old daughter 16 your mother 48
year old grandmother from dushanbe
Brooklyn Kathmandu please Harlem way
Buffalo waiting look at this me logging
will change too oops no that
happens sometimes to change a minute
waiting looking miss me logging waiting
we waiting for papers waiting for
immigration waiting for the answer
waiting waiting for the answer from the
papers that were filed with I NS changed
to be CIA change to USCIS huh change to
Homeland Security the government
see the agent in Nevada New York New
Hampshire it supposed to miss not on a
chair and return all the way around and
address somewhere else what's the answer
her status from the SATs fieles gres
what's her status what's your status in
the country out of the country your
mother father sister brother want to go
back go she wants to go back tere ko
can't get back in can his name should
she go should she stay should she go
there's a woman a man a girl a boy in
high school in college maybe she should
leave maybe go the last day maybe Lee
looking and annoying and waiting to find
somewhere he heads home nowhere to go
back to no good and longing and waiting
to find one where that's hot home so
that was you know something I wanted to
do where I was mixing commentaries that
were airing on the radio and I wanted to
do it live with voices but then I also
wanted to show what it was like being in
kind of this very chaotic school
environment in New York City so skip the
team go to a few more places and we're
outside and I tell the audience after
dash
I have to direct a project for immigrant
teenagers a rehearsal I get there not
one of them has their lines memorized
half of them are running around the room
playing games there's going to be a
performance into me they're all new
English learners they don't have the
lighting camera you don't extend I tell
them you are driving me up the wall okay
look at the wall to see what Stan I tell
them it's an expression I tell them
explaining expression just like opening
a can of worms to the girls scream out
loud the kids take everything literally
note to self explaining expressions is
like opening a Pandora's box at least
there's hope at the bottom and then I
lie down on the floor with the kids
because they're exhausted I'm exhausted
we skip the scene they start telling me
that they're exhausted from having to
speak English all day long so one of the
girls says to me when I talk in English
I have to use so much energy of me I
never looked at it that way in your
language you don't have to think but
when you use English what you have to
think and talk so it's like two kinds of
energy using so I thought that was
really interesting that what does that
mean I'm pushing them to do something
that's my agenda and they're tired all
right so I tell them to sing in their
own languages whatever they want
don't black Michael and a boyfriend
nigeria's start singing songs old and
you don't eat mine cause you hear that
I'm used to like the washroom speakers
what girls starting to laugh again
another girl start no bad thing I
getting idea what about tongue twisters
in your own language another one comes
we they're brilliant there relax you
know this one you know thank you put
your Tower I'm gonna rain check could
you talk after losses in seventy type
report than 22 x given boise visual
treat bags ago my name is money gram
until money whatever miss our wedding
anniversary heavens i couldn't idea i'm
going to take all of these tracks home
i'm going to mix them into one big track
and we can do movement pates and your
own languages will be the soundscape you
won't have to speak english and then on
the stage there's different areas then
there's a little keyboard and a sound
booth station and I go home and the
light shift and so you always know that
when I'm over there that's my home
studio and I mix this stuff into a trap
kids are going to be so happy I played
that for this hip-hop engineer that I
work with Tory he said that's cool it's
like hip-hop listen to the last part
that he says that's cool it's like
Hitler in a single bed I tell it you
can't sample that you don't even know
the kids and I already made that track
that's like stealing he says it's not
stealing it's recreating what you're
doing is like hip-hop I'm not what I'm
doing is any Jews hip-hop say I just
record original sounds that I find
myself and then I make beats out of that
and then I'm not sampling like sliding
the family stone who's finally got paid
or the Beatles or James Brown plus a lot
of your papas you know you guys are big
ego you know surrounded by naked women
to some music I asked her what's the
difference between using half-naked
women to sell music and a corporation
it says she don't know about the history
it's a whole culture hip-hop is an art
form that grew up out of the fires in
the Bronx and came into the light when
there was a blackout in New York City in
1977 19th century sent us the way to go
here made something out of nothing we're
not a desperation or that is desperation
I can relate to that then he says we
need to go to the Rockefeller Center how
you I the line ghostface method a mutant
and charcoal when would I lend itself
q-tip oh boy immortal technique I never
heard of immortal technique so I went to
the rock the bells concert and I hear
immortal technique and then the next
scene is just like so loud you can
barely stand it and I go to the rock the
dancer
worries colorfully consolidates not nice
no medical look like I recite wow he's
roughly without us home I never really
heard some people and try to keep it
quiet and spend the next 25 years trying
to deny get hung for what a cut your
hands off if you make them fit and they
go it's rapping about the kids in the
families I work with how did I get here
and then the rest of the play is really
like how did I get here how did this
seemingly You Know Who am I this middle
aged jewish lady in a rock the bells
concert collaborating this hip-hop
artist it's a little odd right and
working with refugees and immigrants and
you'll all get this I run into a
superintendent in the New York City
Schools and she says hot one name is
Louise we play Judith I saw your show
about the teenage runaway turn deputy
sheriff who blew the whistle on police
brutality you remember that Mississippi
your characters are wonderful I run all
of the programs the new york city for
the alternative school these kids are
right here breath away from going to
jail and you would fit by again a new
characters a wonderful ok cool so I do
need the money I decide to do this you
know I'm going to go to off the road and
I'm going to work in the school and
Louise walks me through the finger
printing process at the New York City
Board of Education the one that behind
the desk tells me it's going to take
three months to get my fingerprints back
was so long firstly Abdullah get Briggs
to be at beyond then we get them back in
a week and that we sit on them for three
months I'm filling out a form in blue
ink that is so loud I can barely read it
there is a space for my date of birth
and then there's a box that says DoD
what's that for wait if I work for the
New York City Board of Education I get
to choose my date of death a little perk
and um so I'm going to stop it there but
I am going to tell you that as the play
goes on these things get revealed in the
way that your interviews people reveal
themselves over time right they tell you
something at the beginning and then you
go back the next time and they tell you
something else and the more you get to
know people the more gets revealed so
the play is structured like that the
girl that says when I took in English
she comes back the kids the story about
starting on 911 comes back and it
becomes clear that their lives are
forever changed somebody's mother can't
get here you know because she came
before how long is it now going to take
somebody from Egypt the voices it was
always my dream to become a pilot not a
normal pilot something exciting like a
war pilot now the war is against the
Muslim people so I changed a little bit
my plans now all I wanna be is a
mechanic for airplanes so you start
seeing like the choices that the kids
are making as the country's changing and
then as the play goes on the old lady I
brought the character back because this
is based on a true story a principal at
one of the schools had seen me do that
character somewhere else and he wanted
me to do the character in his school we
brought a bunch of kids to another
school in New York things get heightened
and you know this is what I'm a little
concerned about when things go around
the web you know they can go really fast
and it can be misinformation that goes
really fast so there was a hate crime in
queens at a particular high school and
everybody immediately what do you think
when you see here hate crime it's like
black-and-white usually a Muslim kid
from Pakistan get this one mrs. queens
had cut off the pony tail of a seat kid
from India is very very serious and
there was tension in his school between
the Chinese kids in the Tibetan kids the
Blue Heron Jewish kids from 2g Stan and
the muslim kids from Afghanistan the
black Americans and the black immigrants
so all the Google countries so this
principal asked me to perform my Jewish
grandmother character because he had
seen me do a story when the character
has dinner with a Palestinian family and
the granddaughter comes back and comes
back with snapshot and the old lady says
you look at the grandma of that family
you look at me the baby look we look
like sisters and they're supposed to
bond the king
and then she says a couple of other
things and at the end of that path I say
I was nervous about sticking my neck out
I thought everyone was going to make fun
of the character and see some old Jewish
lady instead the kids told me they saw
their own grandpa another day another
lesson so as the play goes on immortal
technique actually comes to visit my
class Oh anybody now in my knees like a
rough guy and and then Tory comes back
also at the end though that's cool it's
like hip-hop i'm going to sample that
because as the play gets revealed and
i'm not telling you anything that's
going to like if you want to come see it
this is not going to mess it up for you
trust me but I lived through two deaths
in a fire by the time I was 15 so when
people look at me they're not thinking
that do you know what I mean no single
mother brought her up because of our
stereotypes of who people are and so I
tell the kids could they asked me and
then they want to know how do you
overcome that and the more I reveal a
few little things with kids the more
they ask things and the more they share
things that I don't expect and so those
relationships kind of unfold in the play
and you know some fairly heavy stories
that I wouldn't do in a room on a chair
but with lights and in a theater works
just fine and by the end Tori comes back
and he says you know fires in the bronx
and i say fires in my family black out
of new york city lights out in my head
because I was doing a little parallel of
growing up in New Haven living through
those deaths and fire and then the idea
of fire in my family my grandmother's
family all got
in the Holocaust what was I doing when I
was 20 interviewing all these Holocaust
survivors I used to say that had nothing
to do with me by the way i thought i'd
share that with you and and then as I
got older I started having to deal with
my own memory of that event of her dying
in our house because she took her own
life and so it was very very heavy and
very heavy that that legacy was in my
family and so the circumstances were
tragic and so for years I think I did
what a lot of the kids that I work with
do if they think it means something
about them because kids do that right oh
I can't tell this story because it means
something about me and I felt that way
so it's been a kind of a tool actually
and been an interesting thing for me to
now be giving advice well yeah what is
mayor tickly tickly was he the mayor in
the 60s I wouldn't have been paying
attention in the sixties I was too young
but I who was the mayor in the 70s in
Haven I would have been more aware of
whoever was there like later were you in
New Haven yes ah you're not dickly
aureus
yeah yeah l just shared the Arts is a
group that's in Brooklyn and I didn't
necessarily work with them directly but
I worked with Susan who Susan perlstein
who started it and she's the chair she's
got our voyage nothing chair which is on
our board and we partnered with elder
share the arts for our original funding
for this so they you run that I'm not
leaving this room banter pics thank you
so much you we partnered with her and
she elder share the arts ended up
sending us to this Senior Center where
they had a project going and that was
another thing that we realized was
really unusual in this project that
what's it like coming to the United
States when you're 65 years
for the first time and you speak no
English and that was Susan was
instrumental in leading us to this
unbelievable Senior Center in Flushing
Queens which ironically was getting
renovated at the time and so they had to
share it with a Jewish Senior Center and
we hosted storytelling workshops there
and apparently people had never set
together before the Chinese people set
their the Jewish person when we did a
story tone which I we had them all
sitting together and this woman said
I've never talked to them before and
then it turned out this one woman at a
different Senior Center she was 65 when
she came here she didn't speak any
English but she learned English from her
tutor Frank who was older than her and
he was Jewish and they she realizes they
have a lot in common they ended up
getting married and she told us that she
with making she cooked in very
traditional sexual stereotype marriage
and she did all the cooking and we think
we have a footnote in here because we've
got footnotes of like people stories
that Frank is the only Jewish man in New
York who doesn't like Chinese food
and then she says in here she says
little by little I put Chinese
ingredients in the matzo ball soup it
just was so funny thank you why Chinese
food so she learned how to cook off the
English food oh but you know this was
such an amazing thing for us because
like wow I hadn't thought about that
because most of the immigration stories
that you hear are about young people and
other or adults but thank you so much so
the power of a single person on a panel
is huge or your cars I thank you thank
you so much that packed a grant for
three years and it was fully funded and
we used the money to hire translators
then we got a Ford Foundation grant we
did raise a lot of money for this
project and it needed it and we also
wanted to make sure that the book that
everything was really well done
we didn't want to have a book about new
immigrant stories where it would be like
Jacob Riis sort be like oh and now
here's this person in a basement
apartment we wanted everybody to just
look at their face why I wanted to do it
against white so that you're just always
so he could design around it but also
they're just looking at you and we
realized that when you interview
somebody the backdrop falls away you
actually don't look at the background
when you just looking at their eyes so
he wanted to recreate that experience in
the book visually wow thank you well if
anybody knows of any other funders and
helping us now move this into I think
the thing about archiving is that you
want to make sure that people will be
able to find everything and so is open
to the public yeah all kinds of
wonderful artists playwrights
factors two stories stories it's amazing
right and you need to do it because I
listened to all of these stories like
that was one thing Ramon this guy from
the Philippines said I was doing
ninotchka the other night where she says
I wasn't afraid of being outspoken when
you're like that you walk into trouble
let me arrested me they brought me to
the Philippine Constabulary and they
booked fingerprinting search me the
colonel said do you know that didn't
list the five thousand enemies of the
state to be picked up your number only
had two digits I said first 100 I'm so
honored and so remove it oh well you
really have ninotchka and it's because I
listen to her voice for so many hours
editing for those of you that are
recording people you're just sitting
there transcribing and then we'll do I
like that and you know just got into my
brain and my body so that was kind of
fun you had a question another place in
their American but they did something
called housing start of the circus I was
a circus which is the circus that people
who are trying to get benefits have to
go through how they have to act when I
see there this officer that dr. miss
like Idris it's a circus and where is
the archive no it's actual performances
out performance of our mrs. yes I just
want to thank you so much for doing this
thank you and I just want to say also
that I i also do
and I do it on a theme I interviewed
survivors and after they came here they
go thrived and it really mattered
whether you were seven years old and a
rock was being thrown at you or whether
you came before the war and your parents
were big mockers and he became a big
month where you were on the wheel of
life really is important and so they
they survived and they all the next year
I interviewed nine people and some what
do you think so you could do this kind
of thing on a theme 113 year 103 year
old woman was thankful that's what she
came to America she got a job as a nanny
and she was able to get the paperwork to
get her parents
and a little twelve-year-old was
thankful that what a classmate died her
mom talk about morning and this year
doing it on so you survive to thrive
you're thankful so what is your handle
what are you doing Jill get paid for
that you want to do why do you do and
I've got ten people aged 11 2 91 and the
91 year old moved here to be an actor
from Pittsburgh where he was black and
they just gave him rolls and he
moves to disappear he moves to a part
and there's a gang they're a gang of
high school dropouts with nothing to do
and uses his acting skills and he turns
that gay into a youth group he turned
them around 180 degrees there are people
living today who have changed their
lives because
and he's going to be at the hebrew term
map of going on november 20 seconds for
an interfaith thanksgiving celebration
fight you both come and i'll put up some
flyers and we need to know each other's
stories we need to walk in each other's
shoes also i'll let me know that if you
are around in october october 24th i'm
going to be doing you'll miss that the
nuyorican poets cafe and there's an
opening act of a group of women who are
doing stories about having gotten out of
prison it's really more about their
stories of what their lives have been
like being a prison and they're doing an
opening act and I do have flyers for
that here but you can certainly grab a
card and take that and I just want to
thank I know I'm still standing on this
ridiculous but I just feel like it's a
little known her to other people I want
to thank you so much for having me here
in this space and also for this
incredible class and I know you're all
doing interviews right now my only thing
because you had asked me
people were right in the middle of your
pre-production right is that for me when
I'm listening and I'm recording people I
really have to slow down and listen
really carefully to the language and the
nuance of what people are saying so
you're not yet at that part of the
semester where you're in post-production
or right you're interviewing people so
and if you have any questions feel free
to ask me or email me future thank you
so much